okay so the boy season 3 is now over
episode 8 had a massive ending that set
up a lot of things for the future and
throughout this video i want to give our
big theories or what's going to come
next time step right up step right up we
got your president homeland of theories
and obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the finale then
check out now please hit the thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this each and
every day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
boys and the first major thing i want to
talk about is ryan's fate come the end
of the season he's back with his dear
old dad and without becca being there
he's likely going to end up becoming the
spawn of superman they even end in a
similar way to the omen to hammer home
this idea and it really seems like he's
going to become the second worst ryan in
the world shut the [ __ ] up ryanairy damn
punk now to make matters worse billy
hasn't been given long left to live
because of his overuse of compound v24
this was worn to be fatal in the series
and now because of it he's living on
borrowed time so he hasn't got long left
to save ryan from his father now i
actually think that ryan is going to
become the next soldier boy in the show
in the comics this was one of the only
superhero titles that was seen as a
moniker rather than being for a specific
person there were three versions in the
comics and with ryan being descended
from the first one i can see this being
something that's passed on to him he's
listed off countries just like soulja
boy did in the comics he's worn the same
colors as him and the mantle also has
this idea of him being a patriot which
would help play the homelanders base so
i really think they'll go that way with
ryan and have him as somewhat of a
sidekick to homelander using the mantle
now billy is probably gonna die and you
already know they can't leave homeland
or alive at this point so who will look
after ryan well i actually think that it
might end up being annie and huey come
the end of the series earlier in the
season we got the scene in red river
where huey investigated the adoption
procedures and though he talked about
adopting his two kid as a way in he
could have hinted that to what's coming
down the line now on top of this
starlight of course runs at child
traffic
sorry
she runs that orphanage program but we
know the truth which ryan would likely
end up in once the scorched earth battle
ends up playing out dario was right stop
we don't that's all i bloody knew it now
say by some miracle that belly survives
i think they'd have to do this in a way
that makes sense for the show though i
do think he'll die billy could end up
taking the extra compound v that annie
took from vogt though she gave some to
kimiko to kickstart her powers again
there was a lot left over in the bag now
billy could end up taking this but i
actually think his principles will turn
him against this he's already talked
about how bad b is and i think that
rather than taking it he'll instead
focus on clearing it out from the world
this is something that he also did in
the comics and his final arc revolved
around wiping out everyone on earth who
had v in their system not only did this
include the supes but it also included
the boys who had been using the
substance to level a playing field now
how about you will do this could have
already been potentially hinted towards
in the comics he ended up using a
refined version of compound v that was
linked to little nina early on in the
source material she had created a way to
explode every soup's head by injecting
them with a specialized form of bee that
detonated upon a certain radio frequency
going off billy was going to disperse
this and then detonate it killing all
the supes at the same time now huey
managed to stop him but i think they
might change it up and have it linked to
bcl red in the series we discovered that
this vaporizes the v within someone's
bloodstream and potentially this could
be altered and redefined so that it
doesn't cook regular people's bloods
just the soups it'll have huey asking
annie are you okay are you okay annie
and it would give him motivation to go
out and stop butcher a soldier boy is
currently under the care of the cia in
containment and if he's being studied
then there could be improvements that
end up changing the bcl rate developed
by the russians i'm still standing by
bcl red standing for big chess laser as
well i'm standing by that put that on my
grave and alternatively billy could get
his revenge to altering the v24
substance if he can do this then it can
achieve the similar lethal effects that
he now has and yes it would be ironic to
do it this way now i don't think he'll
end up killing the boys but they may end
up attempting to stop him fully going
through with his plan he's went
toe-to-toe with mother's milk in the
season and annie and maeve have shown
that there are good soups now as for the
seven i'm really not sure how things
will go but i think we are on the brink
of them collapsing several of their
major members are dead with black noir
and supersonic being killed by
homelander in the season maeve is also
lying low and the dma trains seem to be
the only members left due to starlight
ditching them reminds me of boris
johnson's cabinet and going forward they
might end up getting some more members
from the comics jack from jupiter has
been hinted at in the show when we seen
him doing something with uranus
he was also in the boys diabolical so
they've definitely been planning the
seeds for him to show up it was also
missed a marathon in the comics who too
was a speedster and this would create a
rivalry with a train now going beyond
this i think they're all gonna die
outside of the deep i can see a train
sacrificing himself and finally making
amends for everything and the deep
making it through cause
kevin is a idiot and he's exactly the
kind of guy that survives this [ __ ]
nadeeb also ended up surviving in the
comics too come the end of the run he
joined a group called america
consolidated and he changed his name to
true it would definitely fit in with a
character for him to do something like
that and have a complete rebrand after
his reputation is left in tatters now as
for stan edgar i really don't know how
it's gonna go with him in the comics
they pretty much gave his role to
stillwell and edgar was only ever
mentioned as the ceo james stillwell
ended up inspiring madeleine stillwell's
name but the character clearly ended up
being fully adapted into edgar as
they're much more similar super
confusing but when edgar died in the
comics many assumed that stillwell would
take the top spot however he allowed
jessica bradley to do this instead and
this was so that when the company fell
she would take the fall this seems to be
what edgar is doing in the show too and
he calmly left allowing ashley to become
the ceo i think that when it all comes
crumbling down that she will end up
becoming the patsy much like jessica
stan will then take the reins back
disprove his guilt and also expose
homelander and victoria as being in
collusion to frame him now the last
theory i want to talk about is where i
think that they're going to be taking
homeland air throughout the season he's
been making a lot of big power plays and
also saying a lot of things that sound a
bit bit like that they're making him
like a certain real life figure now
whatever your political leanings are we
aren't here to judge but i think these
choices have been done on purpose for
the creative team to potentially set him
up as someone who will rule over america
beyond the obvious similarities in
dialogue showrunner eric kripke said
that homelander is very much an analog
for trump and i think they will try and
steer him towards this homelander has
just started running a billion dollar
company and he's gaining his fans to the
point that i think season 405 will see
him taking the hot seat it also seems
like victoria is taking this route too
and in the comics of vic the veep was
about plant who ended up teaming
alongside dakota bob in the white house
eventually they killed him through using
a wild wolverine and this is when he was
given the job of ruling over america
with him controlling the laws and
government contracts he was able to give
board access to anything that they
wanted however vic's reign was
short-lived as homelander launched his
supe uprising throughout the comics he
slowly started to turn against his
masters and he eventually unified the
supes in order to lead a coup he stormed
the white house and beheaded vic
taunting billy who arrived on the scene
mentioned it in a lot of breakdowns but
if you haven't watched those qui i'll
quickly go through it i think it would
be really ironic if homeland beheaded
vic to make up for her exploding other
peoples never mention that again i
promise either either way this moment
was a major one in the comics and it's
when black noir stepped in he revealed
that he was a clone of homelander who
had slowly sent him insane so that he
could fulfill his mission to finally
murder him we learned that the only
reason black noir was created was to
stop homelander in case he went rogue
but not being able to do this made his
life feel meaningless so he set things
in place to kill him and it all led to
this moment where he could finally take
him down black noir murdered homelander
but with the series carrying out a
mortal combat fatality on him it means
that we can't have this play out
therefore i think homeland might
actually survive this scene and
potentially he could end up going past
this moment this could lead to him
becoming the president and i think it
would be a massive change up in the
dynamics to have the boys fighting the
most powerful person in the country in
terms of not only ability but also
position now if they don't go that route
i think ryan will be one of the main
players that helped take him out kind of
gone back and forth over whether he will
deliver the killing blow but i think
that billy might stop him from doing
this and this will cost him his life too
you might see him take v24 for the last
time which will give him one final power
boost to finally kill homelander before
it takes him out as well i think this
would be the perfect end to his arc as
he'd finally kill homelander and also
stop ryan from becoming a violent
murderer obviously i know everyone will
have their own theories so let me know
yours in the comments below now we are
in competition right now and giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once on the 15th of july and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts and
theories you pick the comments at random
on the 15th and the winners of the last
one on screen right now see if that's
you message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want to be able to watch them
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the finale which will be linked on
screen right now by the way thank you
for sending through the video i've been
paul and i'll see you next time take
care peace